je vais mettre au bois le texte de la
proposition de loi constitutionnelle
merci de bien vouloir regagner vos
places
[Musique]
le scrutin est ouvert
le scrutin est clos
résultat du scrutin votant 387 exprimé
369 majorités 185 pour 337 contre 32
l'Assemblée nationale a adopté la
proposition de loi constitutionnelle
collègue je suis très très émue à la
fois de ce vote et de ce signaler
historique
que l'Assemblée nationale sonore a
envoyé à toutes les femmes de notre pays
mais aussi à l'ensemble des femmes du
monde
je suis très émue de voir que malgré
l'obstruction qui n'en a pas terminé
jusqu'à son terme nous avons su dégager
collectivement un consensus avec la
conscience du temps long persuadé que
nous faisons acte de progrès pas
seulement pour nous-mêmes mais aussi
pour les générations à venir
aujourd'hui collègues l'Assemblée
nationale par le monde aujourd'hui
collègues notre pays par le monde
la France en introduisant le droit à
l'avortement dans la Constitution serait
la nation pionnière en matière des
droits des femmes il est temps que notre
pays s'affirme comme à l'avant-garde de
la protection des droits sexuels et
reproductifs monsieur le ministre
maintenant la balle est dans le camp du
gouvernement nous espérons et nous
sommes nombreuses à l'espérer nous
espérons un projet de loi
constitutionnel qui nous permettent
d'aller plus rapidement sur cette
question
je veux ici remercier chaleureusement et
sincèrement l'ensemble des collègues
députés qui ont permis de recueillir la
sentiment de leur groupe et de
travailler à cette formulation
transparisane je remercie Mélanie Vogel
qui courentusement au Sénat à porter
cette question il y a un mois je
remercie évidemment l'administrateur
monsieur Joly mais l'ensemble aussi des
services de l'assemblée qui ont fait un
travail remarquable je veux enfin dédier
cette victoire historique que nous
envoyons à la fois comme signal à notre
pays mais au monde aux femmes des
États-Unis aux femmes de Pologne aux
femmes de Hongrie dont le droit à
l'avortement et aujourd'hui on travaille
mais aussi et elles sont là aujourd'hui
aux militants qui dans notre pays
lutte au quotidien pour le droit des
femmes à disposer de leur corps je vous
remercie
merci
monsieur le président
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la Présidente
je voudrais d'abord m'associer aux mots
qui viennent d'être dit par les
différents orateurs et notamment par la
rapporteur sur le message historique que
la France délivre à la face du monde et
principalement quand on connaît les
attaques que nous avons rappelé
principalement quand on connaît aussi
notre histoire puisque c'est 50 ans
après le procès de Bobigny j'ai eu
l'occasion de le dire au début de cette
discussion ce que je voudrais vous dire
aussi
c'est ce que nous non de beauté ce n'est
pas le point final
et ce que nous avons fait nous pouvons
le faire y compris sans attendre un
projet de loi du gouvernement c'est pour
ça qu'il était aussi essentiel aussi
essentiel
de réécrire le texte que vous nous
proposez
d'être parfois un peu plus prudent même
si nous ne renonçons à rien sur la
contraception c'est pour ça qu'il était
aussi essentiel de pouvoir inscrire ces
dispositions dans le corps même de la
Constitution et non seulement en son
article premier et c'est pour ça
qu'aujourd'hui nous avons ouvert la voie
un débat dans la haute chambre un débat
qui nous implique tous puisque auprès
des groupes
qui nous représente également auprès de
cette chambre nous avons une
responsabilité un débat qui nous
implique tout et pour lequel je prendrai
ma part en prendront notamment à tâche
avec le président de la commission des
Lois du Sénat pour que ce texte chemine
et je vous invite vraiment à considérer
qu'il ne s'agit là en dépit du fait
qu'il s'agit un grand pas que d'un
premier pas je vous remercie
mesdames messieurs les députés
je prends acte avec beaucoup de
solennité de gravité du vote historique
qui vient d'avoir lieu il y a de cela
quelques minutes
j'ai tout à l'heure dans mon discours
appelé de mes vœux que l'Assemblée
nationale se prononce pour l'inscription
de l'IVG dans notre Constitution
c'est désormais chose faite et bien
faite avec une très large majorité
grâce à la majorité et je veux saluer
ici
Aurore Bergé
je sais
et il m'est pénible de vous vous soyez à
cet instant
l'engagement
viscéral personnel
qui est le vôtre
et je veux saluer ce très grand geste du
retrait du texte que vous avez préparé
de très longues dates
je veux également bien sûr et je
n'oublierai personne saluait
le modem
horizon bien sûr
merci pour cet engagement
c'est l'expression au fond de nos
valeurs communes
grâce à l'opposition également n'ayant
en particulier à la gauche et je veux
saluer le travail de madame la
Présidente panneau aussi les groupes
socialistes
écologiste communiste et je n'oublie pas
bien sûr les membres du groupe liotte
[Applaudissements]
l'assemblée mesdames et messieurs les
députés
envoient aujourd'hui un message fort et
je voudrais vous dire que c'est un grand
honneur et une grande émotion pour moi
d'être parmi vous et d'avoir
porté le soutien indéfectible du
gouvernement vous le savez je l'ai dit
une révision constitutionnelle ça se
fait avec l'accord des deux chambres il
reviendra bien sûr au Sénat de ce
prononcer le moment venu sur le fruit de
nos débats pour que nous poursuivions
cette navette parlementaire sur la
rédaction d'un texte qui marque
évidemment une étape fondamentale pour
le renforcement du droit à l'IVG
quoi qu'il en soit nous réaffirmons que
les femmes disposent de leur corps et
une fois encore point final